THEY ARE HERE, NOW TRYING TO
REFOCUS ON THEIR 2018 AGENDA.
BRET.
>> Bret: THANK YOU PETER.
STRONG INDICATIONS TONIGHT THAT
YOU WILL GET TO SEE THE
CLASSIFIED MEMO THAT REPUBLICANS
SAY DETAIL SURVEILLANCE ABUSES
BY THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
DURING ITS INVESTIGATION OF THE
TRUMP PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
SO FAR, THAT DOCUMENT IS STILL
UNDER LOCK AND KEY.
THE FBI DIRECTOR IS PUSHING BACK
PUBLICLY, SAYING THIS MEMO
SHOULD NOT COME OUT.
TONIGHT WE LEARN JUST HOW RAW
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE MEETING
MONDAY ABOUT THIS MEMO.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE HAS AMAZING
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE RELEASED
A 51 TRANSCRIPT THAT SHOWS
MONDAY'S VOTE RELEASE REPUBLICAN
DRAFT OF MEMO WAS ACRIMONIOUS,
DEMOCRATS.
THIS EXCHANGE, MIKE QUIGLEY
PRESSES DEVIN NUNES OVER WHETHER
HE COORDINATE WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE.
"IF THEY HAVE ANY I.D. WERE
DOING THIS QUESTIONNAIRE" DID
I WOULD SAY WE ARE WELL AWARE
THE PUBLIC OPPOSITION TO THE
AFTER THE TRANSCRIPTS WERE
RELEASED, ADAM SCHIFF
HIGHLIGHTED THE PASSAGE BECAUSE
OF A FOLLOW-UP QUESTION ABOUT
STAFF COORDINATION.
TODAY THE FEUD BETWEEN THE FBI,
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, AND
CAPITOL HILL TOOK A NEW TURN
MISLEADING AND INCOMPLETE.
IT READS IN PART, THE FBI WAS
PROVIDED LIMITED OPPORTUNITY TO
REVIEW, WE HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT MATERIAL OMISSIONS AND
FACTS THAT FUNDAMENTALLY IMPACT
THE ACCURACY.
STRZOK ARE DISPUTED THE CLAIM.
NUNES DISPUTED THE CLAIM.
IN WHAT APPEARS TO BE A
REFERENCE TO THE TRUMP DOSSIER
FUNDED BY THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
AND DNC, NUNES.
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN
SOURCES BOTH MEN HAVE VOICED
CONCERNS ABOUT THE MEMO WITH
ROSENSTEIN "PUSHING BACK HARD."
THE PRESIDENT SEEMED TO MAKE HIS
FEELINGS KNOWN.
THE COMMITTEE HAD NO COMMENT
TODAY ON A POSSIBLE TIMING FOR
THE RELEASE OF THE MEMO IN THE
LAST FEW MINUTES WE'VE GOT SOME
NEW INFORMATION THAT GETS US
SOME CONTEXT ON CHRISTOPHER
WRAY'S REVIEW OF THE MEMO.